it's been a week since we arrived here
in Milwaukee Wisconsin our new home our
new office our new location for
everything reason IO and philosophy
related we came from Kingston New York
and it took about two days to get out
here and we're still in the process of
unpacking that'll be going on for quite
a while we have around 90 boxes of books
being to academics living you know
together and merging our libraries many
years ago we've managed to accumulate
even more we've started to carry a
little bit of triage with those pruning
out some of the books but there's still
quite a lot here what I wanted to do in
this video since people were interested
with you know the photos and the updates
that I posted on Facebook and Google+ is
to talk a little bit about the the trip
out here which was to say the least
eventful so I thought I'd also talk a
bit about you know why we moved back to
Wisconsin and what we're looking forward
to doing out here that we weren't able
to do in Kingston New York where I've
been living for about four and a half
years and my wife and II had been living
for quite a bit longer than that so let
me talk about the trip first I suppose
you could say that the trip began with
getting the moving truck to begin with
because for about a month and a half
almost two months prior to the move I
had been taking things and putting them
into a storage locker preparing for the
move all those boxes of books were were
you know bit by bit packed up and then
put into my my Subaru drove out to the
storage area unloaded there we had quite
a few other boxes full of you know all
the things that make up a household bits
of furniture here and there fortunately
we didn't have too much
and we managed to pare down our our
existence in that respect quite a bit
but there was quite a bit of 10 by 10
probably about 10 foot high storage
locker nearly filled so the Tuesday
before we actually started on on the
road we went and picked up the u-haul
truck and it was quite a truck we
originally were looking at getting a
16-foot front which really would have
been adequate for what we were doing and
then we you know got a little bit
concerned about that and went up to a 22
foot but then they they didn't have one
so they gave us a 26 foot truck and a 26
a truck is really quite a lot of vehicle
to have on the road it's a diesel you
you've got a really long back on you
you've got to know what you're doing
with the mirrors and as I learned from a
tow truck driver that this is part of
the story down the line there's there's
a lot involved in that it has air brakes
it's not the sort of thing that that
somebody like me who doesn't drive truck
for a living really ought to be handling
in any case we got the truck and we
managed to get it home and then take it
out to the storage area we had movers
come in and that was kind of nice
watching these professional movers work
because these guys were really strong
right now one was six foot five the
other one was probably not quite six
foot tall and these guys have been
working together for quite some time and
I watched them take the the storage
locker that had taken me a month and a
half off and on to pack into the storage
area I watched them go through that in
about an hour you know the tall guy I
could pick up three bankers boxes worth
of books all at one time and pile them
and that was quite amazing to watch him
they didn't even break a sweat these
guys and so it was pretty incredible
they packed everything in very tight in
part I think because they didn't realize
how much we'd moved from the apartment
to the storage area so when they got to
the
they made pretty quick work of that as
well our furniture the remaining boxes
they knocked all of that out and we had
a lot of room in the truck to spare you
know you can see that we didn't really
need this this gigantic 26 foot truck so
then we you know we are wrapping things
up and we had a day to sort of get ready
and packed the last remaining things and
then we got up the next morning and
there was a not only did we have our
truck there that we had to finish
loading up our landlord he had a
tree-cutting service coming in that were
cutting down trees so we had to run a
gauntlet with the last items and with
the the dogs to take them past these
guys who were operating a lot of heavy
equipment we got ourselves on the road
and started heading out of Kingston the
truck wasn't handling particularly well
it had been you know a little slow as
far as pickup went even in the city but
there weren't any indicator lights on so
you know we didn't we didn't really know
what was going on so we got on the road
and you know we're jockeying back and
forth we got onto the interstate I had
to go through the tolls manually because
you know you can't use it at high pass
with some sort of moving truck like that
it's a whole different classification
we're making decent time and then a
light came on and the light was for de F
fluid and I have no idea what this is it
turns out that it's diesel exhaust fluid
it's one of these additives that has its
own special tank that is supposed to
improve the exhaust so that the diesel
fumes don't aren't so damaging to the
environment which is a good thing in a
job but it's a bad thing when it starts
going off so we ended up calling the
Penske service line and they were very
helpful you know they tried to walk me
through it had to get to a truck stop by
DF DF fluid the tank was our
more or less full so I filled it up some
more and the light didn't go off and I
talked to the guy and he didn't he said
well one of two things is going to
happen either you're able to drive the
truck because it's something like a
sensor and it's not really going to pose
any real problem with you it won't shut
you down or it could be a line or
another type of sensor and then in that
case that you'll lose power and the
truck will just essentially drive at
about five miles an hour and as I found
out later this doesn't happen all at
once you lose your power gradually you
lose your torque and you eventually
descend to only being able to drive rum
five to 10 miles an hour but that didn't
happen for quite some time so we're
making good progress we're driving along
you know the gas gauge isn't going down
very much at all because it's a huge
tank and and my wife got you know a good
ways how to make if she's driving a car
and and I would find that as I would go
up hills and you know remember we're
driving in Pennsylvania in the mountains
so there's some pretty long grades this
truck is just not doing well on great so
I call the Penske guys I say is this
related to the DAF thing it says no it's
it's just the truck you know these these
things are not designed to you know
maintain their their speed going up
along grade so I was going down to like
you know 55 miles an hour 45 miles an
hour 40 miles an hour and I have the
pedals of the floor so you know by now
I'm getting a little bit concerned
because it's taking longer and longer
and longer and then about 3/4 of the way
through Pennsylvania the truck starts
not only to you know slow down as we're
going up it you know on grade it's also
not speeding up as we go down great
because as we would go down I could get
the truck going up to like you know 70
miles an hour so I could make up a
little bit of the lost time now it's now
doing that now the trunk is starting to
go just 50 miles an hour now it's going
just 45 miles
and I'm thinking great this must be
related to the DF thing how far am I
going to be able to get before I am
totally you know I'm going to out of any
sort of options and you know driving
along at ten miles an hour on the
interstate people are passing me you
know semi trucks are passing me blaring
their horns and I see that there's a
rest area up ahead you know about two
miles so I figured okay I could make
that by the time that I got to that rest
area was able to turn off that truck was
going only ten miles an hour by that
time I already pulled them off onto the
shoulder because they had I almost got
hit by it by a semi that you know wasn't
really paying attention and was
barreling down on me in in the right
hand lane probably going a good 65 or 70
so it was getting pretty dicey I managed
to get to the rest area and now it's
another call to the the service people
and I said look this truck isn't going
anywhere there's a lot of protocols that
have to be observed by now it's starting
to get dark and my wife is already you
know on her way to the hotel in
Youngstown which is our sort of halfway
point you know we're driving halfway
there one day and then the rest of the
way to Milwaukee the next day so you
know he puts in a call and the service
guy comes by in about an hour and hooks
up some equipment nice kid had a good
talk with him about you know what he did
and the software that was involved you
always learn a lot of interesting things
a lot of the way if you talk with people
about this but he couldn't make heads or
tails of it in part because the truck
was actually an off-brand and the
service software that he had with all of
his equipment wasn't set up to do
anything with that
so Penske by this time has already
called a tow truck a semi tow truck to
come by and get the truck and and to tow
us all the way to Youngstown including
it which means going across state lines
as well
so not a very tow truck can do that it
takes about another hour for the tow
to get there and then to hook up there's
a little thing you know there's quite a
bit of adventure with that involving
moving stuff from from the cab of my
truck over to to her truck it turns out
to be this this trucker lady who'd been
driving truck most of her life and had
just recently decided you know she
didn't like doing over the road trucking
she liked doing towing in part because
it kept her closer to home pretty nice
lady a lot of stuff that we had to talk
about you know kids dogs you know what
was going on in Pennsylvania why I
shouldn't have been driving that big
truck to begin with and anyway she gets
it she gets it hooked up and that takes
a bit of time and you know it's a good
hour and a half ride to Youngstown at
that point now I you know it's been rain
has been raining and wet you know I'm
getting kind of tired being on the road
and this is just the first day we
finally get to Youngstown and now you
know you know we have to drop the truck
laughs she's a little bit worried about
getting it through the parking lot
understandably so because her rig is
quite long and the truck itself is quite
long it's got a 26 foot compartment and
then the rest of it out there
so she eventually you know dumps it in
in the back drops it gets out and and
you know prepares it for just staying in
place and being towed the next day so
the question is then what are we going
to do Penske had sent another truck by
that time a 16 foot truck and had
arranged with some some movers not
professionals this time but rather a
crew that you know does this sort of on
the side they're driving from Pittsburgh
so everybody is driving from all over
the place to make make these things
happen and from 12 o'clock at night to 3
o'clock in the morning we're there you
know out there with these movers off and
on watching them transfer stuff from one
truck to the other truck going from a
huge 26 foot truck to much smaller 16
foot try
we actually got rid of a few items where
we were like look we're not going to
take this with us we were probably going
to donate that anyway
and everything is packed in as tight as
can be and these guys are not
professionals so things are kind of
topsy-turvy and there's going to be a
little bit of load shifting the next day
in any case we managed to get to bed we
get some sleep we get on the road the
next day I think around noon maybe so
now we're driving out to Wisconsin so
now it's you know we're on the second
half of the trip you know it's all it's
not really all downhill from here
but it's at least you know getting
closer to our destination we're not
gonna have to stay somewhere else that's
not you know where we want to be we will
stay in a hotel the next night but
that's just because the apartment isn't
quite ready yet
so you know that day went pretty pretty
smoothly
there were a few things where it got a
bit dicey in Chicago you know I'm
driving through you know the downtown
I'm 94 and I had some lady it managed to
basically cut me off twice in her
Volkswagen Beetle just not paying
attention at all and not thinking about
the fact that well you know a car or a
pickup truck can stop fairly quickly
it's not smart to you know drive out in
front of a moving truck because these
things take a little bit more time to
come to a spot so there's a bit of load
shifting that takes place during that
time but we managed to get to the hotel
and it turns out that it's the the La
Quinta in Waukesha the very edge of
Waukesha or Waukesha meets Brookfield
technically I think it's Brookfield but
I thought we think of it as Waukesha
because I used to live there and I used
to work at the Kentucky Fried Chicken
which is still there right next to the
La Quinta I would have to ride the bus
from the downtown terminal of Waukesha
out to Kirk
corners and then crossed the interstate
and then actually this is a whole
different story but I would walk back
home along the interstate for a while
and then on highway 18 about three miles
to get back to to my mother's house
after work just silly stuff that went on
during during the late 80s in any case
we you know we get a good night's sleep
and now it's time to meet up with the
other movers the other professionals
that we've got here to go into the
apartment to handle everything to sign
the lease to you know find out about the
amenities and so we go and do all that
and my wife's parents were kind enough
to come out and take care of the dogs
so you know so we don't have them
underfoot and we come out here and it's
you know a beautiful place it's a great
you know I mean being on the road is not
a lot of fun and you know hotels can be
quite nice sometimes but it's not quite
the same thing as being home and you
know here we arrive and we go to the you
know meet the people that we were going
to take care of the paperwork with we
find out about all the different
amenities involved here we can see the
wonderful view out of the the window on
the sixth floor where we're handling
everything and now we're getting quite
excited I think well I think my wife was
already quite excited but now I'm a bit
more excited because you know the things
are really happening but we still have
the the rest of the movement so we've
got the truck you know we go back at the
truck park in the loading zone the
movers arrive therefore actually from
Chicago so I talked back and forth with
them a little bit about where they are
in Chicago and you know my family a lot
of them still live in that area and then
you know it's it's a good five hours of
them more or less just you know
unpacking the trunk onto the street and
then going and using the elevators you
know
take a load after load after load up
here to the apartment and to drop stuff
wha
took quite a bit of time I'm outside for
most of it you know watching man's
apartment you sure nobody comes along
just grabs our stuff and by now you know
I'm not supposed to be you know doing
any idiot lifting because we got these
young guys to do it which is very smart
but I don't think I would have wanted to
lift anything because I'm dog-tired and
you know my back is kind of tied up in
knots from all the driving and and some
of the lifting that I did at other times
the movers were not quite happening the
professional movers the job that the non
professional movers had done in the
middle of the night because they looked
in and they could see things were just
like a lot of kilter they're like what
what is this you know there was a little
bit of swearing involved but overall it
wasn't too bad there was a little bit of
breakage you know a few things that we
lost that's usually going to happen and
any move most of them were fairly minor
things fortunately nothing that can't be
replaced and now we're here so now it's
a matter of bit by bit by bit as as we
you know continue working because and
Andy and I are both you know working a
lot of the time developing new new you
know routines and habits and slowly
unpacking all of these these boxes and
taking things into storage taking things
out of storage we're now at the point
where the kitchen is completely setup
which is great we've got some things you
know we've been looking at what's the
order for as far as you know the things
for the bedroom or the living room we're
not quite sure whether I'm going to
build a bunch of bookshelves or whether
we're going to find some other recourse
we've already started going through the
boxes of books and doing a bit of triage
deciding to take some of them to used
book stores and sell them off the things
that we don't really need or the things
that
and easily get at the library we got
ourselves into a position where we
really do have too many books you know
when you have a marriage of two
academics both of whom you already have
an extensive library and both of whom
are bibliophiles and both of whom are
willing to indulge the other and say hey
let's get some more books you end up
with a lot of books so there's there's
all of that now I said I was going to
mention a little bit why we actually
moved here and then that's fairly
straightforward you know Andy and I are
both from this area I grew up in a
little town called Wales which is quite
a bit west of Milwaukee and is still
fairly countryside although most of the
development of the surrounding area has
been quite developed but at the time
that I grew up it was really a
countryside she grew up closer to
Milwaukee in Brookfield at a time when
there was still a lot of green space in
Brookfield but where you know it's still
a more urban environment Waukesha would
be sort of the dividing line between us
we went to high school together and you
know coming back to this area for us is
really great Andy has lived outside of
Wisconsin in New York for close to two
decades I have been gone from Wisconsin
in a variety of places ranging from
southern Illinois which is really a
whole different state from the rest of
Illinois Indiana North Carolina and then
moving up to New York I have been
outside of Wisconsin for 20 years and so
we're really happy to be back here and
moving in Milwaukee is happening the
city there's there's a lot of great
stuff going on here culturally the food
scene is just amazing there's there's
all sorts of you know great museums and
libraries if we get again to go to
someplace that's a bit bigger Chicago is
just an hour and a half down
and really looking forward to
reconnecting with a lot of old friends
and even some of the family that I don't
get to see that often and he's really
happy because her family is here as well
so she gets to see them you know the
past it was basically holidays and now
we get to see people whatever we want to
and we have the challenge of building up
sort of a new business network and a
network of places to do speaking gigs
and do consulting but we're we're on our
old home turf I mean we did okay out in
New York I was never really in New York
I guess Andy you could say it's arguably
a New Yorker she certainly knew her way
around there but it's something
different when you're back in your you
know original home environment so we're
really looking forward to all the things
we've got coming up here I've already
got one event scheduled for stoical week
in November I'll tell you more about
that in the update video for November
and during stoical week but yeah great
experience a little bit of hiccups
during the move itself but I do have to
say the Penske people as far as their
customer service goes pretty good and
things could have gone a lot worse so
we're really happy to be here I'm happy
you know Andy's happy the dogs are happy
and I'm guessing that you know as we
start meeting up with more and more old
friends and family they're gonna be
pretty happy about it too so that is the
whole story of the move up to this point